amazon is investigating after one of its
echo devices recorded a family's private
conversation and then sent it to a
person on their contact list a portland
oregon woman says she had no idea that
her Amazon echo listened to her and her
husband and then shared their
conversation with one of his employees
yikes Gary Hawker of our Seattle
affiliate that's Cairo TV broke this
story Gary good morning well good
morning the woman whose name is Danielle
says that she was shocked to get a phone
call urging her to disconnect her Alexa
devices right away after her experience
she's vowing never to use them again my
husband and I would randomly joke
sometimes like I bet these devices are
listening to what we're saying until two
weeks ago
Danielle's home in Portland Oregon was
wired in every room with the Amazon echo
her family used the Alexa app to do
everything from turn up the heat to turn
off the lights
but Danielle told us via Skype that
their love for the Alexa changed with
one alarming phone call person on the
other line said that person was one of
her husband's employees calling from
Seattle he proceeded to tell us that he
had received audiophiles
recordings from what was going on in our
house Danielle says an Amazon echo
device in her home recorded a private
conversation and sent a recording of it
to the cellphone of a random contact
which was the employee in Seattle about
175 miles away this is part of that
conversation
Danyelle unplugged all of the devices
and repeatedly called up Amazon she says
an Alexa engineer investigated her story
did he tell you why it happened he said
that the device guessed what we were
saying in a statement to CBS Amazon says
quote background conversation was
interpreted by Alexa as commands to
record and send a message as unlikely as
this string of events is we are
evaluating options to make this case
even less likely we have absolutely no
right to listen and record my
conversation it's unheard of
well Amazon says they take privacy very
seriously they called this a rare
occurrence and they're investigating to
ensure that it does not happen again
Nora all right Gary hooker of Cairo TV
thank you I've had already trouble yes
imagine if we were listening to the
conversation at the Tracy home John said
we hear him in and say oh I love my job
how great or no hankie on good thing
they were only talking about hardwood
floors I know I've got a two of those
devices in my home like different makers
very old
sometimes they interrupt conversation as
if we've said something so this feels
like they're laughing all the time all
right
delete it if something gets it from our
house don't post to that Instagram but
if the flowers ever are you are John